what's in the box what's in this box
that i so perfectly wrapped
um
this is a gift for you for me the
company that i work with
um
that um
their factory is in addis ababa
uh in ethiopia which is my favorite
place in the world my daughter was born
there really yeah and i just got choked
up saying that and uh
yes
and and she cries on tv okay
um and they make room for they there's
uh
sex trafficking has exploded in ethiopia
and one of the largest open air markets
is in addis ababa and women
young girls get off the bus every day
and they're being auctioned off within
you know an hour and a friend of mine
and his wife started a company called
parker and clay and it's just ironic
that it's called parker and clay but we
became
really close and we actually have
traveled to ethiopia together and they
have adopted children from ethiopia as
well and they make the most beautiful
products they employ 80 percent women
they've taken so many women from the
street and i've visited the red light
district in
august and it's pretty
harsh so um
so many of the profits go but they also
stay they live there they work with the
people fair wage they get lunch it's a
beautiful factory i've been to the
factory and look what it has on it
yeah and it's um this i like to think of
as like
a picnic bag because you can put a water
bottle in it and the other side you can
put like little snacks and food
and then this one is just like a
beautiful tote that and it's yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
anything else you want from there
anything i'll get it for you incredibly
me yeah you can catch mary louise in how
i learned to drive on broadway now 25
years
from when according to broadway yeah
david moore's first minute
that is so and trying to revive broadway
is so important to me i'm going i'm here
it's an hour and a half no intermission
oh i love it
and this is just so thoughtful and
beautiful i cannot wait to sport it in
life and carry you with me
i love that as well so much deep and
meaningful thing thank you guys so much
[Music]